speaking of uh blimps Donald Trump is in
the news
[Music]
yeah he was I could tell the 24 campaign
is already on you know he had his first
rally in South Carolina last week and I
could tell it's on because he's going at
me again
today he called me a low rating sleaze
bag oh
[Music]
I do not have low ratings
[Applause]
who laughs at conservatives because he
thinks we're weak and stupid
foreign
but he's got competition this is
interesting we've we have an official
race now Nikki Haley former governor of
South Carolina is uh going to announce
on February 15th so that's pretty
interesting and she's got a great slogan
to start her campaign the Republican
party now with women
[Applause]
and uh
but here's how I can really tell the
campaign's underway already it's only
February of 23 but because Trump is
starting to give people nicknames
she's going to be tricky Nikki or or
something you remember Little Marco and
low energy Japanese he's going at it
with Ron DeSantis run to sanctimonious
what that means he said Ron just think
the moonius is a rhino globalist now if
you don't have your
English to Republican code book
Rhino means not crazy enough
globalist means Jew
and the sanctimonious I think means I
have dementia I don't know
he's so weak and stupid
and oh and another Republican is
probably going to get in the race former
governor of Maryland Larry Hogan
exactly uh yeah Trump is not too worried
about him
his nickname for him is Larry Hogan
but hey you know what if he's going to
go up against Biden he's going to have a
tough time fighting on the economic
front we had the best jobs report pretty
much that I could ever remember I think
most people can remember
uh
this month we had over 500 000 jobs they
haven't had a report like this since the
moon landing
or if you're a Marjorie Taylor green the